I gotta ask I'm sure you get these
questions all the titles but you know we
had some news out this morning right so
they're going to now kale we're gonna
have kale come on the Albert are gonna
have vegetables finally so they're gonna
have breakfast all day yeah I I'm
curious like I so this morning I charted
where McDonald stock has gone since the
2004 movie and look I mean they've you
know doubles more than you know their
returns are enormous rocks wise but you
know for you I mean what do you think
about mcdonald's now and how the company
is trying to recover I mean there was
they made an announcement I when it was
it a few weeks ago that they were gonna
suddenly start serving pure chicken
chicken that wasn't filled with a
Michaels antibiotics and I was like what
have they been feeding us up till now I
think the question you have to continue
to ask yourself is what is in this food
yeah announcement give them a break do
you ever want to give them a break why
why give them the break yeah they're
there you know until they start you know
serving like really good positive food I
think that we need to push them as much
as possible